- [Narrator] In two German
cities lies the birthplace
of a worldwide arts revolution.
One which looked to strip
buildings from unnecessary
adornments and build the
foundation of what is called
modern architecture.
Welcome to the home of Bauhaus.
It all started here,
Weimar University, 1919.
This is where German
architect, Walter Gropius,
alongside other artists,
founded the Bauhaus movement.
His office alludes to what
the architectural style
would become-a force for
clean, simple designs
fit for the everyday life.
Not too far away in Weimar
is the first official
Bauhaus building, Haus am Horn,
built for an exhibition in 1923.
Its clean lines and lack
of adornments might look
average today, but, almost
one hundred years ago,
it was truly revolutionary.
Seventy miles away in Dessau,
the movement continued in 1925-
initiating its most fruitful period.
The most stunning representation
is the Bauhaus Dessau.
Seen as the pivotal building
in Bauhaus, this structure
amazed the world with its
steel frame construction
and asymmetrical plan.
Nearby, you also have other
buildings in the Bauhaus style.
The industrialist minimalist aesthetic
is visible in all of them.
In 1932, the Bauhaus
school moved to Berlin,
where it dissolved itself a year later,
due to the Nazi regime.
Nevertheless, the movement
spread all around the world,
creating an international trend
for all other spheres of art.
(electronic pop music)